[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu den richtigen
fragen hierbei bilder ist corona
endgültig vorbei seitdem der krieg da
ist das fragen wir jetzt im
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach bei uns im studio dank auch
ihrer fragen zu hause ihrer zuschauer
fragen und ich fange gleich mal an mit
dem kommentar er laut aber von yvonne
müller die schreibt uns liebe bild ich
bin so wahnsinnig wütend auf euch auf
uns in dem fall man findet überhaupt
keine schlagzeilen mehr zum corona waren
sind nur noch ukraine also ist nicht so
sie stellen sich heute der korona
sprechstunde hierbei gilt aber natürlich
gibt es ein spannungsverhältnis zwischen
diesen beiden themen erst recht wenn wir
die bilder aus mario pohl derzeit sehen
aus dieser völlig zerbombten völlig
zerstörten stadt in der ost ukraine das
sind drohnen aufnahmen von dort lauter
wenn wir solche bilder jetzt jede stunde
immer wieder aufs neue im fernsehen
sehen die brutalität dieses krieges
sehen dieses putin angriffskrieges
können sie verstehen dass der eine oder
andere millionen möglicherweise in
deutschland sagen angesichts solcher
bilder angesichts dieses krieges corona
ist eigentlich nichts mehr was mir angst
macht
das darf man nicht gegeneinander
ausspielen und zunächst mal möchte ich
sagen dass dieser brutale
verbrecherischen angriffskrieg von putin
die berichterstattung verdient
diese bekommt das ist der bekommt also
das ist tatsächlich also etwas das die
menschen sehen müssen und
was auch medial genau in der offenheit
aufgearbeitet werden muss wir jetzt
sehen das ist schlicht und ergreifend
eine katastrophe die sich in zeitlupe
vor unseren augen abwickelt und ist
man kann es nicht beschreiben ist wenn
ja auch krankenhäuser zerstört es werden
kinder also einrichtungen zerstört es
gibt keine praxis mehr die noch
funktioniert die menschen verstecken
sich dieses grauen muss dargestellt
werden daran können wir nicht vorbei
geht dass das medial so aufgearbeitet
wird wie jetzt das verstehe ich und
daher ist die berichterstattung mit
diesem schwerpunkt das geht wollen
völlig klar dass das was auch in unseren
köpfen macht man kann sich ja nicht
umziehen krisen gleichzeitig kümmern und
vor der sie in sachen gleichzeitig angst
haben selbst die renommiertesten
psychologen sagen an der stelle
eigentlich kann der mensch sich nur auf
eine angst gleichzeitig konzentrieren
das heißt man blendet jetzt krone aus
coruna ist vorbei in dem moment ja es
wird zum teil nicht mehr so viel
berichtet das kann ich auch verstehen
und bei coma ist es ja nicht nur dass
man mit der angst haltige arbeiten
darauf dass er sich sogar zahlt sondern
wir müssen halt
aufklären und wir müssen warnen dort wo
angemessen und wir müssen versuchen
regeln zu schaffen die funktionieren und
wir müssen versuchen hilfe zu geben das
ist ja auch andere gründe das habe ich
heute mich wieder den fragen der
zuschauer stellen weil sie halt beste
falsch mit angst zu arbeiten dass
michael falsch mit angst aber das wird
mir hier ständig unterstellt dass noch
mehr häufigste zuschauerfragen ja genau
und das ist ja auch etwas was also von
also
ihrem blatt und auch also von ihren
kollegen mir oft also unterstellt wird
aber ich arbeite schlicht nicht mit
angst mache
das muss man klar sagen das ist ein
unterschied ob ich mit angst arbeite
oder ob ich mit einer realistischen
einschätzung dessen was passiert also
arbeite ich bin ein beispiel wenn sich
jetzt ein ungeimpfter infiziert und
denkt omikron also 70 jahre alt ist für
mich nicht so gefährlich eine milde
variante dann würde ich erklären das ist
nicht so er hat dann doch ein
erhebliches risiko dass ins krankenhaus
muss da ist er vielleicht schwerer
erkrankt dass er möglicherweise
verstirbt und dass er möglicherweise
werden das überlebt bleiben durch seine
warnung
und da würde gar keine zweifel sie also
wenn man wenn man in der vergangenheit
mit prognosen gearbeitet hat die weit
über das hinaus geschossen sind was
anschließend ein getreuer eingetreten
ist das ist das was zuschauer immer
wieder kritisieren auch im vorfeld
dieser sendung und sagen halt na ja
daran sieht man ja der arbeitet halt mit
angst der macht der ist ein panik
minister ja aber wenn man erst erstens
also die prognosen die ich gemacht habe
ich habe selbst ganz wenige
modellierungen gemacht und die waren
übers noch nicht mal so schlecht
aber ich beziehe mich meistens auf
modellierungen anderer spezialisten
beispielsweise eine modellierung von kai
nagel oder eine modellierung des robert
koch instituts und wenn diese
modellierung dann also die realität die
später eintritt nicht so komplett
bezahlt weil auch zum teil unserer
maßnahmen gewirkt habe dann ist das
keine angst mache sondern ich habe mich
auf der grundlage der besten
vorliegenden wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse habe ich eine prognose
vorgestellt aber das ist doch keine
angst mache wenn die prognose dann
nachher noch so lange anhalten lassen
jetzt einmal sind jetzt kurz weg
gekommen von dem einen punkt die eine
angst und die andere angst ist das was
sie möglicherweise auch an sich selber
feststellen sie werden krieg schauen
auch vermutlich jeden tag werden sich
genau diese bilder die wir gerade
gezeigt haben auch ständig anschauen
auch im kabinett ist das natürlich thema
sie sind selbst mindestens ja mehr als
am rande betroffen in ihrem ressort von
diesem krieg zum beispiel über die
flüchtlings lage dort das heißt stellen
sie das bei sich selber auch fest eine
verschiebung des interesses der
aufmerksamkeit weg von corona nein auf
keinen fall also ich bin ja für die
groner bekämpfung zuständig und wenn ich
sehr unaufmerksam würde und würde mich
anderen themen zu stark widmen das wäre
nicht akzeptabel meine aufgabe ist es
nicht der verteidigungsminister ich bin
nicht der innenminister sondern also ich
bin der gesundheitsminister ich muss
dafür sorgen dass alles was mit diesem
krieg zu tun hat und was gesundheit
betrifft so weit wir das regeln können
gut funktioniert also gott zum beispiel
bekommen die flüchtenden die hier nach
deutschland kommt bekommen die die
medikamente oder sie versorgen die sie
brauchen sofort sind wir in der lage
hilfsmittel medizinisches mit
betäubungsmittel narkosemittels in die
also gebiete zu bringen wo die menschen
das bauch und wald zu menschen zum teil
also wird dort das sind doch
schmerzmittel knapp narkosemitteln
betäubungsmittel knapp das muss rein
mario pohl ist alles knapp
beispielsweise auch mit bürgermeister
sagt gerade bei uns in der sendung wir
leben hier wie im mittelalter aber wir
müssen die medizinischen hilfsgüter die
müssen wir als land bringen das ist
etwas woran ich mitarbeiter wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass die ersten und hast du
aus deutschland die helfen wollen dass
sie das auch können entweder in der
ukraine oder in polen in den anderen ein
anders dort helfen können und
schließlich wir fangen auch jetzt an
menschen die in der ukraine verletzt
worden sind oder verwundet worden sind
in deutschland zu versorgen wenn die
ausgeflogen werden zuerst aus der
ukraine in die westukraine und dann nach
polen und dann werden die über so ein
system verteilt das kleeblatt system was
wir bei dem coup war nämlich schon
genutzt haben da bin ich auch mit
zuständig aber das sind die dinge wo ich
mich konzentrieren zivilisten oder auch
soldaten also darüber möchte ich hier
nicht auf vortragen auf jeden fall wir
helfen wo wir können es werden menschen
ausgeflogen das system beginnt hier
nicht in dem ausmaß sind dass jetzt die
ersten oder genau dass die ersten die
ersten also das system muss ja erst mal
funktionieren muss wird dann getestet
also diese ersten tests haben
stattgefunden das wird jetzt mehr werden
und also das heißt es gibt schon
ukrainische verwundete das lassen wir
mal
die hier versorgt er genau die er
versorgt werden also wir haben das jetzt
also vor ein paar tagen erstmal nix los
gezogen das ist die ganze kette
funktioniert also aus der west ukraine
polen dann aus polen nach deutschland
verteilt über ein gemeinsames also
lagezentrum von also bund und ländern
und dass dieses kleeblatt system im
science also was wir auch bei der
pandemie gehabt haben bei den comic
patienten somit als somit diese vier
bereiche da bin ich auch mit zuständig
längst nicht allein da sind die anderen
ministerien innenminister im
außenministerium der schwerst verletzte
sind das intensiv lass uns noch mal so
stehen betreuen lassen ist zum beispiel
das sind leute die eine sehr also
intensive versorgung benötigen und die
also in also intensiv medizinische
einrichtungen also verteilt werden
müssen und das läuft jetzt an das
wichtig deutschland liefert nicht nur
waffen warum ist das so geheim ganz kurz
ohne da in die privatsphäre der menschen
einzugreifen muss jetzt mal gar nicht
aber warum dann also gar wird ja auch
mehr zeit wird darüber wird auch mehr
berichtet werden aber jetzt läuft er
hier ist erst mal an meine art damit so
etwas umzugehen ist die lassen sie uns
darüber sprechen wenn es wirklich eine
größenordnung also
erreicht hat die es auch wert ist wir
bereiten das jetzt werden das gut
vorbereitet die finanzierung steht dass
er schlicht noch nicht schmücken mit
einem mit der vergleichsweise klein
genau das ist was ich hasse ist
sozusagen das leute sich mücken mit
etwas was angekündigt ist aber noch
nicht läuft ich will es wirklich also
wir werden darüber zu sprechen ich wäre
empfang am morgen beispielsweise werde
was was volle pulle schon läuft stellt
das paket ist die eu kommissar für
gesundheit die wird morgen mein gast an
da gehen wir nach tegel also in das
dortige flüchtlingszentrum jetzt impfen
so gut organisiert hat den impfstoff so
gut besonders ja so aus man sich jetzt
in den letzten monaten eine vorzügliche
arbeit gemacht ich arbeite gerne mit ihr
zusammen sie ist auch so hoch engagiert
beide also corona bekämpfung und auch
bei der vorbereitung der und mit ihr
arbeite ich eng zusammen sie ist mein
gast unser gast der wir werden also in
tegel seien werden wir also die sache
somit ankündigen was schon läuft nicht
ankündigen was in planung ist okay da
müssen wir sie dann später daran herr
minister raane wer diese frage haben wir
im vorfeld dieser sendung gestellt groß
auch auf bild.de wer hört in dieser
corona pandemie eigentlich noch auf sie
unsere zuschauer haben dann ganz eigene
meinung was ist ihre antwort auf diese
frage wer hört noch auf sie ich sage es
noch vieler auf mich dahingehend und ich
bin es ja nicht allein auf die
wissenschaftler auch hören dem
expertenrat die bundesregierung somit
auch mich beraten diejenigen die noch
maske tragen diejenigen die noch
vorsichtig sein die sind diejenigen die
nach einer infektion die quarantäne und
isolations regeln beachten das sind
nicht wenige es ist richtig dass also
hier
leider muss man sagen in der
berichterstattung also eine der eindruck
entstanden ist dass also omikron eine
sehr milde variante ist und der andruck
ist nicht ganz richtig für diejenigen
die um games sind oder diejenigen die
risikofaktoren haben ist das halt nicht
der fall wir haben nach wie vor ein
erhebliches risiko daher sterben jeden
tag also zwischen 200 und 300 menschen
das ist so viel wie damals haben wir
gleich noch mal darauf zu sprechen auf
die zahlen auch auf die sterblichkeit
werden gleichzeitig eine wahnsinnig hohe
dunkelziffer das haben sie gerade am
freitag noch gemeinsam mit lothar wieler
auch festgestellt dass heißt wir wissen
eigentlich relativ wenig über die
tatsächlich hospitalisierung die
tatsächliche sterblichkeit dass sie
jetzt einmal einsteigen etwas tiefer mit
einem fotovergleich aktuell auf
politischer bühne olaf scholz dort
unterwegs einmal im bundestag und einmal
in brüssel unterwegs im europäischen rat
und sie sehen es einmal klar so kann man
es in deutschland so sind wir alle im
moment bei der arbeit unterwegs und dann
in brüssel sieht halt einfach rechts
sehen sie es anders aus da wird sich
locker die hand gegeben der wird
gescherzt da wird ohne maske rumgelaufen
also derselbe kanzler unterschiedlicher
ort wie konsequent ist es die länder
haben unterschiedliche regeln und die
unterschiedlichen regeln also müssen
beachtet werden deutschland hat
verhältnismäßig strenge regeln immer
gehabt ja durch die gesamte partie nie
dafür ein teil dieser regeln zeichne ich
selbst auch verantwortlich selbst in der
zeit als ich noch gar nicht minister war
ja vielleicht noch mehr in der zeit
sogar damals auf jeden fall auch und ich
finde das waren keine schlechten regeln
das hat dazu geführt dass wir in
deutschland gegeben wie alt unsere
bevölkerung ist das nicht absurd aber
saßen nämlich trotzdem fragen
beantworten schön sonst sonst völlig den
faden und kann nicht mehr das wäre doch
schade was nämlich den punkt sagen also
die verhältnismäßig strengen regeln die
wir haben uns auch gut gedient wir haben
vergleich zu anderen ländern mit einer
ähnlichen altersstruktur haben wir eine
deutlich bessere sterblichkeit und das
ist gelungen obwohl wir eine geringe im
boot haben somit werden zwei handicaps
das ein handicap alte bevölkerung das
zweite handicap viele risiko leute im
älteren semester insbesondere die sich
nicht haben ihn verlassen dass wir dann
trotzdem die geringe sterblichkeit hat
dies nur den strengen regeln zu
verdanken sonst wäre das nicht
darstellbar wie viel höher ist jetzt für
den kanzler die gefahr in brüssel
als im bundestag weil
die inzidenz also in belgien ist ja
moment niedriger als beim als bei uns
von da aber ich möchte das nicht also
die die lage ist doch klar die regeln
sind hier andere sind strengere dann
unsere regeln sind aus meiner sicht
richtig der bundeskanzler hält sich an
die regeln die vor ort notwendig sind
und üblich sind und daher hat er alles
richtig gemacht in der nächsten woche am
nächsten samstag ist sozusagen unser
kleiner unser mini freedom day ist es so
ich hoffe nicht das würde ja bedeuten
dass die maßnahmen dann alle auslaufen
bis auf den in den einrichtungen für
besonders gefährdete gruppen also
meinetwegen pflegeeinrichtungen
krankenhäuser ich glaube dass wir bei
der incidents die wir derzeit haben die
hotspot regelungen die ich mit
justizminister buschmann gemacht habe
dass also die länder die benutzten
werden wie jetzt in mecklenburg
vorpommern also geplant auch in hamburg
ich hoffe dass also auch andere länder
nachziehen und hierzu also regeln kommen
die gerade in den städten und lanthan wo
wir sehr hohe instruments haben nur noch
hohe sterblichkeit haben die die regeln
so nutzen dass dort mehr schutz möglich
ist als wenn man auf die regeln
verzichtet und einfach also so tut als
wenn die pandemie vorbeisetzte sagte
erstmals läuft alles aus das ist richtig
aber es läuft nicht aus wenn die
landtage beschließen neue regeln sich zu
geben enorm das gesetz mitgemacht das
besagt es läuft alles aus genau wo außer
in den hotspots
jetzt werben sie dafür dass das ganz
große hotspots gibt das ganze länder
sich zu hotspots erklären heißt auf
eurer seite
sagen sie ich bin dafür ich
unterschreibe das gesetz ich betreibe
dieses gesetz um es tatsächlich gesetz
werden zu lassen das alles ausläuft ich
möchte auf der einen seite das alles
ausläuft und auf der anderen seite
möchte ich das fast ganz deutschland
doch dann eben wieder keine auslaufende
maßnahmen haben ja das ist ja kein
widerspruch sondern es hat ja einfach
eine recht nein überhaupt nicht das kann
widerspruch das hat er einfach eine
rechtliche komponente der rechtliche
hintergrund ist der der justizminister
in qua amt hat auf der grundlage also
der bewertung der also situationen
gesagt eine deutschlandweite gefährdung
der gesundheitsversorgung ist nicht mehr
gegeben
daher sind deutschlandweit
einschränkungen rechtlich nicht mehr
machbar um enden sie mir dann nennen sie
mir eine region oder ein großes
bundesland bei dem sie im moment sagen
würden da bin ich froh dass alle
maßnahmen auslaufen
das ist doch ob ich froh bin ich hatte
sogar gesagt rechtlich geht es gar nicht
anders also sage ich mal ganz im ernst
dass jeder kapiert rechtlich wäre es
nicht möglich gewesen egal wer
verhandelt hätte
deutschland weiter regeln auf rechts
warten weil es eine deutschlandweite
gefährdung nicht mehr aber es wirkt
inkonsistent und es wirkt unehrlich sie
unterschreiben erst in der ampel
regierung das gesetz mit das sagt aller
maßnahmen laufen aus und dann
anschließend kommen sie daher und sagen
ich wünsche mir eigentlich dass ganz
deutschland ein hotspot ist das habe ich
nie gesagt ist es das ist eine
unterstellung und zum zweiten hier geht
es nicht um münchen sondern hier geht es
ja um also was ist möglich es war auf
der grundlage der rechtlichen analyse
vom justizminister nicht möglich
bundeseinheitliche regeln zum beispiel
masken pflicht in ganz deutschland zu
beschließen es war einfach richtig
möglich ob ich das jetzt wünsche oder
nicht oder ob buschmann das will ich ja
sagen wir buschmann hätte gesagt ich
will jetzt die masken sich in ganz
deutschland hätte es auch nicht machen
können denn auf der ganz grossen sonst
völlig den faden kommen nicht mehr
selbst buschmann wer nicht in der lage
gewesen wenn das justizminister
buschmann wer nicht in der lage gewesen
jetzt zu sagen macht sich in ganz
deutschland war auf der grundlage seiner
eigenen juristischen analyse sind solche
einschränkungen nur noch möglich
deutschlandweit nicht in hotspots wenn
es eine deutschlandweite gefährdung gibt
weil sie haben ja gerade gesagt das sei
eine unterstellung dass sie jetzt nicht
wollten dass ganz deutschland ein
hotspot wäre das heißt wo ist aus ihrer
sicht im moment möglich dass alle
maßnahmen fallen also dass tatsächlich
das passiert was in ihrem gesetz stehen
mein wunsch ist natürlich mein wunsch
ist und war natürlich dass zum beispiel
die masken pflicht in ganz deutschland
gilt das ist ja klar und das war auch
mein wunsch während der verhandlungen
also auch jetzt würde ich wenn das
rechtlich ginge die masken pflicht für
ganz norddeutschland wollen hat und kein
epidemiologe wird es anders wollen und
auch im expertenrat werden
wahrscheinlich alle der meinung dass die
masken pflicht in ganz deutschland jetzt
sinnvoll wäre aber das ist doch gar
nicht die frage sondern die frage ist ob
es dafür noch eine rechtliche grundlage
gibt und da war die antwort des
justizministers ist nicht mehr da wo
kann aus ihrer sicht im moment auf die
hotspot regelung in deutschland
verzichtet werden verzichtet werden kann
überall dort wo die gesundheit muss
verzichtet werden dort wo die
gesundheitsversorgung nicht gefährdet
ist aber sie können keine region denn
sie sagen jetzt sein weil sie fehlen ja
auch die region nennen das haben sie
auch öffentlich getan wo sie wollen dass
die hotspot regelung im moment ja aber
leider meck pomm ich werde am montag
außer die gesundheitsminister der länder
also quasi in
einer gesundheitsministerkonferenz
darüber informieren was aus meiner sicht
die kriterien sind nach denen also
bundesländer die hotspots bestimmen
können und die kriterien sind eigentlich
ganz einfach zu nennen ist in einer
region oder in einer stadt oder
vielleicht nach dem ganzen bundesland
die also im
versorgung im krankenhaus so gefährdet
das zum beispiel planbare eingriffe im
moment nicht gemacht werden weil zu viel
personal ausgefallen ist oder zu viele
kurven patienten im krankenhaus sind das
ist das erste das zweite ist die
notfallversorgung durch diese
krankenhäuser kann nicht mehr
dargestellt werden das dritte ist also
wenn in der pflege werden unter grenzen
die wir quantitativ festhalten die
werden unterschritten und das filter ist
die krankenhäuser müssten patienten die
schon da sind in andere krankenhäuser
verlegen was sie nicht mehr versorgen
können mit diesen vier kriterien wären
die länder in der lage die hotspot
regelungen umzusetzen darüber werden wir
sprechen und ich appelliere einfach an
die länder jetzt ich weiß dass das
gesetz kompliziert ist ich weiß dass das
nicht schön ist wenn die landtage das
beschließen müssen aber es ging ja nicht
an also ich bin appelliere an die länder
ist jetzt zu machen trotzdem ist zu
nutzen die länder werden mit dem
gleichen problem konfrontiert also jetzt
zum beispiel schlägt gesundheitsmittel
hologic aus bayern er schlägt vor lasst
uns doch dem fast in ganz deutschland
ist dann vorschlagen und dann ist es
eben so der ministerpräsident sind total
dagegen ja aber ist ja egal also ob er
das vorschlägt oder nicht das ist
vollkommen unerheblich es geht rechtlich
nicht das ist ja das problem ist dass
das ja wie ein trick von lauterbach bei
den menschen ankommen doch ihre landung
stellt sich hin in berlin und sagt mit
den grünen und mit der fdp dann fallen
am nächsten samstag alle maßnahmen und
derselbe minister derselbe
gesundheitsminister setzt sich
anschließend hin und sagt ich werbe aber
dafür zumindest in etlichen
bundesländern dass dieselben maßnahmen
eben nicht fallen das kommt bei den
menschen die ein trick ja gut also dass
von dort also als erstes also ich habe
einiges also
hier vorzutragen aber ich habe keine
tricks nötig das ist nicht mal eine art
das ist also die unterstellungen die
saat ich lese dass manchmal höre dass
und so weiter sondern damit beschäftigt
nicht mal wie es ankommt weil die frage
ist doch wenn ihnen jemand sagt herr
lauterbach ich streiche dass das gilt ab
samstag nicht mehr und dann kommt ihr
ministerkollege und sagt das geht doch
noch es hat nur jetzt jemand anders
beschlossen ist es natürlich für den
betroffenen bürger am ende wurst ja es
bleibt beim selben recht es bleibt bei
denselben maßnahmen ist hat mir jemand
anders beschlossen nee das ist nicht der
unterschied wäre es beschlossen hat und
dann der unterschied ist die
rechtsgrundlage
anders ausgedrückt erstmalig habe dafür
gesorgt dass wir bis zum zweiten vierten
überhaupt einen übergang haben sonst
hätte es schon den freedom day sofort
gegeben es wäre ja fast gar nicht mehr
zu einer einigung gekommen wir haben ja
bis zur letzten stunde verhandelt ja so
dass es überhaupt noch einen übergang
gab wenn die tatsache dass wir jetzt
überhaupt dann übergangen haben bei
dieser riesigen fallzahl ist ja muss man
ja ganz offen es ist ja buschmann und
mehr zu verdanken die praxis gar nicht
ansatz und zum zweiten ich muss immer
nur sagen
wenn die rechtsgrundlage für
einschränkungen in deutschland weiter
nicht mehr gilt kann sie nur noch lokal
gelten und werden sie lokal aber also
somit haben wir jetzt die situation
bundesrat geht es nicht mehr lokal
gegner ist und viele der länder
schmollen und mache noch wahlkampf sich
sagen der bund hat uns im stich gelassen
im lokal klingt ja als wäre jetzt ein
teil von berlin oder wie der westteil
von paderborn betroffen aber die
wahrheit ist ja dann das ganz
mecklenburg vorpommern heißt oder ganz
bayern dazu eine frage die es nochmal
runterbrechen dieses problem ja
einerseits fällt die masken schlecht in
den supermärkten auf der anderen seite
haben sie sofort gesagt sie werden dafür
dass die supermärkte das durch ihr
hausrecht einfach umsetzen unserer
zuschauer harald bands aus heimsheim
fragt er lauterbach warum schieben sie
ihre verantwortung und damit den
schwarzen peter jetzt den supermärkten
zu die mit ihrem haus rechten masken
pflicht durchsetzen sollen den gesetzes
pflicht sie mit der regierungskoalition
nicht festlegen konnten also sie kriegen
das nicht geregelt und jetzt schieben
sie den schwarzen peter so sagt er dass
den supermärkten rewe zum beispiel sie
aber du bist doch immer die gleiche
antwort die rechtliche grundlage für
mich das zu machen ist nicht da sonst
hätte ich das gemacht ich hätte so zu
sagen wenn die rechtliche grundlage da
gewesen wäre hätten wir die masken
pflicht nicht verloren sie wäre ja sagen
ganz deutschland die richtig aber ich
hatte keine rechtliche grundlage
die masken pflicht in ganz deutschland
durchzusetzen weil die gesundheitliche
gefährdung in ganz deutschland dafür
nicht mehr da ist wenn jetzt ein
supermarkt auch auf meine empfehlung vom
hausrecht gebrauch macht dann ist die
rechtliche grundlage dafür da bei einer
sache für die es keine rechtliche
grundlage mehr gibt weil die
gesundheitliche gefährdung nicht mehr
ausrichten gegeben ja bei dieser frage
hat rewe mehr macht als der
bundesgesundheitsministerin ante
hausrecht nutzen kann und der
gesundheitsminister an dass solche
masken pflicht nur beschliessen könnte
wenn es ganz deutschland so ginge dass
wir eine gefährdung der gesundheitlichen
versorgung gefährden befürchten müssen
könnte es sein dass wenn die frage nicht
so wichtig ist dass sie's regel dürfen
sondern nur rewes regeln darf dass die
frage dann vielleicht gar nicht so
wichtig ist und man einfach die maske im
supermarkt nicht mehr tragen müssen also
ich kann es ja nur empfehlen ich hätte
auf jeden fall wenn die rechtliche
grundlage dafür da gewesen wäre die
masken pflicht war das ein verfahren ist
wo ich mit geringem aufwand viel
erreichen hätte ich das fortgeführt und
jetzt kann ich einfach nur appellieren
an die ende in den hotspots das zu
machen und ich freue mich auch wenn das
also supermärkte machen das ist gar
keine frage reagiert eigentlich haben
wir haben edeka rewe penny aldi lidl und
so weiter haben die alle gesagt habe es
ja weiter in der bundespressekonferenz
gesagt ja also ich werde am montag die
reaktionen bekommen und kann ihnen dann
gerne berichten ich kann es zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht aber tatsächlich
ist das eine grundlage ist wie gesagt
mir ist wichtig in der heutigen zeit
wird ja oft gearbeitet mit narrativen es
werden geschichten erzählt da ist und
das ist daher gelungen da hat sich der
durchgesetzt und so weiter und so fort
in der politik heißt mehr lernen heißt
siegen also genau
märchenstunden und so weiter und so fort
wichtig ist dass man bei diesen dingen
auch die fakten beachtet und fakt war
hier die grundlage des
infektionsschutzgesetzes in seiner
reform war die dass wir nicht mehr das
bund für die nicht wollen haben gruppen
einschränkungen beschließen konnten das
ist im wesentlichen auch übrigens eine
rechtslage gegen die ungeimpften ich
habe diese rechtslage nicht geschaffen
und ich habe eben schon gesagt wenn es
eine andere gelbe wert sogar froh
gewesen aber die grundlage ist die wir
machen nicht mehr viel um die
ungeimpften zu schützen noch einmal zu
rewe zu aldi penny sollen die das nur
den hotspot hotspots durchsetzen ihr
hausrecht die massen pflicht umzusetzen
oder soll das in ganz deutschland das
habe ich doch gerade schon gesagt ich
hätte mich gefreut und hielt es für
sinnvoll wenn wir eine maske pflicht in
ganz norddeutschland der genannt ich
habe ja also nur dass wir das muss ja
gut ich muss das noch mal wiederholen so
dass das zuschauer gut kapieren und so
hat uns wenn die rechtliche grundlage
dafür da gewesen wäre das hätte hätten
wir an der masken pflicht für ganz
deutschland war nur dass die dass jeder
versteht also aus epidemiologischer
sicht wäre die masken für ganz
deutschland sinnvoll gewesen sie ging
aber nicht weil die rechtliche grundlage
ich frage nur deswegen nach weil das ja
kompliziert werden können halten im
landstrich in dem man kaum noch infekt
aalen hat das machen werden der
marktleiter von penny daher gehen muss
und muss sagen sie mir das ja einen
neukölln
wenn es kompliziert es ist auch nicht
wünschenswert
haben sie aktuellen überblick wo
eigentlich am nächsten samstag die
freiheiten die korona maßnahmen komplett
fallen das kann niemand haben weil die
beschlüsse fallen ja in dieser s
kommenden woche und können sie es im
moment über den daumen pein betrifft das
die hälfte deutschland die länder hörte
die länder also haben sich noch nicht
deklariert ich hoffe dass die länder
also viele länder warten ab was passiert
ist in den nächsten tag was machen
andere länder viele länder beobachten
sich viele länder im wahlkampf sehr für
parteipolitik damit gemacht ich finde
ich schade ich würde mir wünschen dass
wir doch mein appell an die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz morgen sein
dass wir hingehen und sagen schaut auf
diese vier kriterien überlastung der
krankenhaus dort wo das der fall ist
sagen wir das denn trotz sie machen das
einheitlich möglichst einheitlich dann
kennen wir gut voran eine frage von
unserem zuschauer nils renschler der
sucht den zeitpunkt wann sagt der
lauterbach eigentlich und damit meint er
ja kein datum sondern der mann einen
zeitpunkt wann die pandemie tatsächlich
für sie vorbei ist wir hören von ihnen
immer wieder die pandemie ist nicht
vorbei wann ist für sie also der
zeitpunkt gekommen wo genau das passiert
was muss dafür die voraussetzung seien
laut die pandemie ist ja weltweit ist
geschehen und wie wird auf absehbare
zeit nicht ändern bringt ein beispiel ja
wir sind großes problem in china der
mittlere teil von china ist
weitestgehend ungeimpft und wo geimpft
mit dem stoff den ich wirklich gut
wirken es besteht aber zu befürchten
dass in china eine riesige welle
losbricht also weil dort also diese hoch
ansteckenden varianten nicht wirklich
abwendbar sind dass ich dann da neue
varianten entwickeln ist sehr
wahrscheinlich auch in afrika da haben
wir wahrscheinlich um die 15 prozent
gegenstück bisher dort also können sich
auch jederzeit neue varianten entwickeln
auch in europa ist jetzt sind die
fallzahlen sehr hoch in england steigen
die fallzahlen
also deutlich an dass hier könnten sich
neue varianten entwickeln omikron die
omikron ist derzeit sagen wir sehr
ansteckend nicht ganz so gefährlich
gefährlicher als viele leute denken
gerade ältere aber nicht ganz so
gefährlich aber das sind nur wenige
mutationen die dafür sorgen dass auch
mitkommen nicht ganz so gefährlich ist
die dafür sorgen dass das in diese ganz
tief in die lungen abschnitte nicht
eindringt wenn in mutationen also dann
eine variante entscheiden steht omikron
die eu also diese besonders tiefe lungen
abschnitte auch willi besonders tiefen
blumen ab stark betroffen sein da haben
wir ganz andere lage somit wie jemand
der jetzt darüber spekuliert wann ist
die pandemie vor beieinander es ging ja
nicht eben um ein datum das kann man ja
ganz klar sagen also dem moment wo weiß
ich nicht das virus sich nicht mehr
weiter gefährlich
entwickelt oder war es ist derzeit das
land erstmals sehr hoch interessant
genau das ist ein hochinteressanter
frage die wissenschaftlich der ist halt
nicht zu beantworten ich bin ja mit
vielen wissenschaftlern im engen
austausch die sich mit der weiteren
entwicklung der panne sehr intensiv
beschäftigen und also das ist ja ein
privileg was ich habe dass ich sozusagen
als minister aber auch quasi als
wissenschaftler kann ich wirklich mit
den klügsten und also am besten
qualifizierten corona wissenschaftlern
weltweit im gespräch seien nur das tue
ich auch in der tat und da ist keiner
der sich jetzt festlegt viele es gibt
kein pandemie exit es gibt zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt kein klares pandemie exit weil
wir nicht genau wissen wer welche
varianten kommen als hoch
sind zum beispiel varianten denkbar
gegen die die jetzigen impfung nicht
wirken dann müssen wir zu neuen impfung
kommen somit also ein panama exit kann
man nicht wirklich vorhersagen ich kann
sagen was im herbst kommt also im herbst
werden wir entweder mit nikon oder mit
omikron abkömmlingen oder also mit also
varianten des ersten serie typs der im
wesentlichen aus der delta also linie
kommt so zu tun haben und werden auf
jeden fall wenn wir die impflücken nicht
schließen durch die impfpflicht werden
wir im herbst wieder mit sanktionen
arbeiten das ist ja das was christian
drosten der chefgeologe hier aus berlin
gesagt hat kürzlich in diesem interview
in den tagesthemen bereich
das heißt nach ostern ist es warm dann
wird das geschehen abgemildert sein aber
es wird auch nicht komplett stoppen wie
im letzten jahr ist meine voraussage
jetzt mal also ich würde schätzen das
schaukelt sich zum sommer wieder hoch
wir haben kein infektions freien sommer
aber es ist eben ein sommer wenn wir da
zum beispiel in innenräumen war maske
tragen dann kann man das geschehen so
moderieren dass es nicht außer kontrolle
kommt und dann kommt der winter da muss
man auch wieder härter durchgreifen
also der nächste corona winter steht uns
bevor
ist das ist leider zu befürchten daher
werbe ich ja oder kennen ich habe nicht
ich kämpfe für die allgemein
nebenpflicht stellen uns folgendes vor
folgendes szenario wir kommen
einigermaßen gut über den sommer dann
kommt der winter also der herbst läuft
einigermaßen aber dann käme
beispielsweise eine neue variante oder
es geht einfach nur um mikro man stelle
sich vor die zahlen gehen wieder hoch so
wie jetzt 300 tausend fälle am tag 300
tote aber dann ist eben nicht wie jetzt
das gute wetter vor uns sondern der
winter steht vor uns dann müssen wir
natürlich maßnahmen ergreifen weil also
stellen sich werden werden wir jetzt vor
dem winter stunden bei den jetzigen
fallzahlen haben jetzt schon die
überlastung der krankenhäuser ich habe
über die hotspots gesprochen gerade dann
müssten wir reagieren und dann wären wir
wieder einmal und das würde auch die
wirtschaft massiv herunterdrücken weil
viele also viele also sein wie
wissenschaftler
wirtschaftswissenschaftler habt oder
auch also
konjunkturforscher aber auch viele
unternehmer denken das ist im herbst ist
es vorbei aber wenn wir dann im herbst
die wirtschaft nimmt er sowieso im
moment einen stoß wegen der ukraine
krise wegen des krieges wegen des
furchtbaren krieg ist aber wenn wir dann
plötzlich die nachricht verbreiten
müssen wir müssen wieder bereiche
zurückfahren wir müssen wir dann würde
auch die die wirtschaft dass wir eine
rezession wäre nicht ausgeschlossen
somit selbst aus ökonomischer sicht ist
es einfach fahrlässig dass wir den flug
nicht schließen und daher appelliere ich
auch an die union auch hier an friedrich
merz selbst wenn man von der
epidemiologischen gefahr nicht so sehr
beeindruckt es was ich schade finde weil
es sind hunderte menschen die jeden tag
sterben aber selbst wenn er sagt dass es
für mich jetzt so nicht so maßgeblich
dann ist aus wirtschaftlicher sicht ist
es einfach absolut notwendig dass wir
jetzt handeln darüber streiten wir
gleich auch über die impfpflicht
weitermachen eine ganz kurze pause sind
gleich zurück mit dem ministerium
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
hierbei bild
[Musik]
zurück bei bild die richtigen fragen an
den bundesgesundheitsminister an karl
lauterbach und wir reden natürlich auch
mit ihnen wieder über zahlen jetzt haben
sie schon in dieser sendung auch immer
wieder diese 300.000 genannt die zahl an
neuinfektionen die sie in wahrheit ja
aber auch nicht kennen sie selbst
sprechen von einer gewaltig hohen
dunkelziffer aktuell das heißt
eigentlich ist das doch eine gute
nachricht wenn die dunkelziffer so hoch
ist dann ist ja die sterblichkeit die
hospitalisierung noch viel geringer
aktuell durch omikron als wir sowieso
schon auf dem zettel stehen nein sie
wird ja nicht geringer das sind ja
absolute zahlen die mich interessieren
wenn 300 menschen am tag sterben ist es
unerheblich also wie viele sich
infiziert haben diese hand leute sind ja
tot wir haben ja gerade mit ihnen über
hospitalisierungen und über ansteckung
usw gesprochen aber dann lassen sie uns
bei der zahl der toten bleiben die hat
eine rolle gespielt auch in der
pressekonferenz mit lothar wieler dem
rkw schauen wir noch mal ganz kurz rein
wir beklagen die 300 tote pro tag und in
der letzten woche ohne insgesamt wieder
mehr als 1000 mitmenschen als todesfälle
registriert in verbindung mit cupid 19
er hat sich verrechnet sie oder her
wieder ich hatte ja auf den tag nicht
bezogen also wir haben ja in den
wochentagen haben wir mehr tote und am
wochenende wären weniger gezählt wir
haben ja am wochenende wegen der
erfassung der todesfälle viel weniger
sind manchmal nur 25 30 tote weil eben
nicht voll erfasst wird die toten werden
dann an den tagen danach registriert
sodass also an den wochentagen hörer
todeszahlen sind also wochen ist sie
haben sich jetzt bewussten wochentag
rausgesucht an dem es hoch ist weil der
eindruck entsteht ja in derselben
pressekonferenz sie sagen 300 am tag und
sagen dann in der fußnote unten da ich
meinte jetzt den heutigen tag morgen und
übermorgen wird die rechnung niedrig das
haben sie ja nicht dazu gesagt ich hatte
ja sagte in derselben pressekonferenz
das sind deutlich weniger
das ist so ist es keineswegs gemeint
gewesen wenn ich mich auf die also wenn
ich sage bis zu 300 tote sterben am tag
oder gestern sind bis gestern sind 300
tote zu beklagen gewesen
dann also ist das also relevant die die
zahl der toten pro woche habe ich dann
davon habe ich ja nicht gesprochen und
er habe aber setzt sich relativ leicht
ausrechnen dass hatte in dem moment
haben auch viele zuschauer gemacht wie
zum beispiel heiko prull der genau das
gesehen hat und der uns auch noch mal
darauf aufmerksam gemacht hat und er
sagt zu einer allzu der aussage von
herrn lauterbach das täglich 250 bis 300
menschen an corona versterben auf welche
quellen statistiken bezieht sich herr
lauterbach kennen sie die zahlen nicht
oder interpretieren sie die bewusst
falsch ich interpretiere keine zahlen
bewusst falsch das mache ich ganz
grundsätzlich nicht und die zahlen
werden ja vom robert-koch-institut
täglich veröffentlicht das heißt es sind
die gleichen zahlen es sind die gleichen
zahlen der punkt ist er also am
wochenende werden manchmal die
todesfälle nicht komplett registriert
aber
die
täglichen todesfälle werden ja
aufgelistet und somit hat man am
wochenende weniger todesfälle und in der
woche hat mir war der komplette rest so
wichtig ist und das war ihm ja auch in
der argumentation wichtig auch um noch
mal auf die gefährlichkeit von corona
abzuheben um das noch einmal deutlich zu
machen wie viel corona tote zählen wir
müssen wir aktuell zählen in deutschland
pro woche etwa die also die zahlen
dieser woche habe ich aktuell nicht aber
wir zählen alle toten und listen die
gesamtzahl der toten tagesaktuell auf
der homepage des robert koch instituts
und sind in den letzten wochen
sind tausende tote dazugekommen wir
liegen jetzt bei fast 130 tausend toten
und ich finde muss ich ganz offen sagen
wir niemanden zu nahe treten aber ich
finde also diese also art und weise zu
versuchen
die glaubwürdigkeit des
robert-koch-instituts noch meine
glaubwürdigkeit infrage zu stellen weil
man deswegen am wochenende komplett
gezählt wird dann ein nicht richtig und
das haben wir nicht getan und das ist
auch nicht die absicht von unseren
zuschauer gewesen sondern er war
tatsächlich daran interessiert das zeigt
ja diese frage wie viele sinn stallone
und der ganz redlich gefragt wenn sie
nebeneinander sitzen herr lauterbach in
der pressekonferenz und sie sagen es
sind 300 am tag und der chef des rk ii
sa es sind 2.100 prof das ist nicht ganz
richtig sprach von 250 bis 300 am tag
und ich glaube an den tagen also davor
waren es jedes mal eher 300 als 200 das
sind die täglich es ist so sind die
täglichen todesfälle das am wochenende
nicht komplett also
gezählt wird
das ändert doch nichts daran dass auch
am wochenende die menschen sterben das
ändert überhaupt nichts daran es ist ein
drama das nach wie vor nicht gezählt
wird ja dass die zahlen an solchen tagen
so große schwankungen erleben ja das ist
ja aber auch gar nicht der punkt gewesen
sondern wie gesagt sie saßen
nebeneinander unterschiedlicher angaben
gemacht und der zuschauer sitzt davor
und sagt was ist das jetzt und warum
sagte er es so und der ist so ja gut das
war also die ich hätte
auf die täglichen todesfälle und das ist
das was relevant ist wenn jetzt mal mit
wegen in der woche jeden tag in der
woche wo die wo die erhebung
vollständiger ist am wochenende ist
schwieriger weil dann zum teil nicht
komplett aber wenn ich jetzt fünf tage
hintereinander habe wo also 200 bis 300
tote sterben das muss doch was nachricht
genügen das kapiert doch dann jeder was
verstehen sie doch dann ich hab's doch
vorher verstanden ja ich habe es nicht
verstanden weil sie nebeneinander saßen
und sich gegen seine nach widersprochen
wir haben uns diese irritation ist bei
ganz vielen entstanden aber lassen wir
jetzt möglicherweise auflösen alles gute
ich wenn ich reagiere da ein bisschen
angefasst weil also
immer wieder also wird also diese
diskussion die wir haben am wochenende
wird nicht komplett erfasst also bis
dahin wird statt weniger druck das wären
dann läden gelockt am wochenende ich
haben würde ja oh das war nicht mal
ansatzweise teil meiner guten aber ich
höre dass immer wieder auf den sozialen
medien bekomme ich ja diese fragen auch
oder diese idee also sind die leute mit
quitte und anke wird gestorben und so
weiter und fordert sind alles ist recht
ich mag sie ja umso korrekter zu sein
gerade in solchen pressekonferenzen die
die menschen tatsächlich wahrnehmen als
hochamt ja was ist wenn man das du hast
wäre dann hier meine pflicht gewesen
hätte ich sagen sollen am tag sterben
250 bis 300 tote ich muss aber darauf
hinweisen am wochenende wird nicht
komplett gezählt möglicherweise hat sehr
viele ja in dem moment auch falsch
gemacht der eine hochrechnung über die
woche
die heraus geblasen hatte sich mit ihren
angaben haben dabei so ist das design
stimmt habe ich nur die idee wäre dann
ja gewesen diese woche sterben uns jeden
tag 200 bis 300 tote aber am wochenende
haben wir keine vollständige erhebung
ich bin aber es kann daher genug ist
nach so lange aber nun aber das lassen
da muss man auch ein mindestmaß an also
vertrauen haben wir in der
bundesgesundheitsminister sich da also
hinstellt und sagt also wir uns sterben
250 bis 300 tote am tag das muss man
dann auch erstmal auf sich wirken lassen
überlegt was können wir machen um die
das hätte jeder getan wenn ich im selben
moment fast im selben moment als app des
lkw plötzlich andere zahlen wir ziehen
kurzen strich drunter und sprechen über
die impfpflicht herr
bundesgesundheitsminister
kanzler scholz war hier als er noch
nicht ganz kanzler war und hat diese
impfpflicht angekündigt das war im
dezember hat angekündigt dass er sich
dafür stark machen werde dass das im
bundestag entschieden werde jetzt haben
wir die uhr schon ein bisschen weiter
gedreht mittlerweile sind ende märz und
wir haben die impfpflicht noch nicht
nicht gerade ein zeichen von
führungsstärke also zunächst hat er ja
was ich richtig fangen sofort sehr
schnell das zu einem thema gemacht wo er
auch dafür steht dafür bin ich dankbar
weil in vielen anderen europäischen
ländern wird die impfpflicht gar nicht
debattiert da stellt sich kein
regierungschef dahin und sagt wir
brauchen den sieg weil es ja auch in der
bevölkerung umstritten olaf scholz hat
das getan dafür bin ich sehr dankbar und
ich bin absolut der gleichen meinung wie
er wir brauchen
dass es dann länger gedauert hat dass es
dem verfahren geschuldet wir haben es
dann haben uns dann gemeinsam
entschieden dass es ein verfahren es wo
der deutsche bundestag die allgemeine
impfpflicht anbringt und nicht die
regierung das war die entscheidung da
kann man unterschiedlicher meinung sein
ob das klug ist oder nicht ich halte das
für eine richtige entscheidung ist eine
wichtige ethische entscheidung einmal
die ldp es nicht wollte und da das ist
eine unterstellung ist es auf jeden fall
so die die fdp auch wenn die fdp das
blockieren wollte könnte sie es auch im
parlament das heißt die fdp ich brauche
die ich brauche die abgeordneten der fdp
auch also wenn ich das also durchsetzen
will im bundestag die fdp ist dann ja
nicht weggeben muss mit stimmen und die
fdp hat ja sogar durch den abgeordneten
ullmann einen sehr guten antrag sogar
gemacht von daher alles gut ich glaube
dass zum schluss einfach zählt ich
blicke immer nach vorn es ist jetzt zeit
vergangen ich blicke immer nach vorn ich
bin also hier mal im
infektionsschutzgesetz aber so mehr war
rechtlich möglich ich arbeite mit dem
was möglich ist ich blicke immer nach
vorn und hier ist bei der über der
impfpflicht ist es so wir haben es nicht
hinbekommen jetzt steht es strittig ob
es überhaupt kommt ich kämpfe dafür ich
blicke immer noch frauen ich versuche
immer das beste herauszuholen mit den
gegebenen möglichkeiten
jetzt sagen sie den menschen aktuell das
nicht zwingen noch ein nächster booster
eine vierte impfung sie werden
einerseits dafür dass die vierte impfung
nötig ist auf der anderen seite sagen
sie für die impfpflicht aber ist das
wiederum nicht nötig warum ist das so
warum gibt es diesen unterschied also
zunächst die dritte impfung schützt
schon den allergrößten teil derer die
drei mal geimpft sind vor schwerem
verlauf und für euch das sollte wird
verstanden somit also es reicht um die
allgemeine impfpflicht durchzusetzen das
ist auch die position der meisten
wissenschaftler auch die maßen also
mitglieder der fachgesellschaft für
immunologie der deutschen gesellschaft
für immunologie trägt diese position ist
es wissenschaftlich unstrittig dass man
mit drei impfung gut durchkommt jetzt
gibt es allerdings also bei älteren
immer noch dann nach drei impfungen eine
kleine gruppe die trotz der dritten
einige sterben auch und wenn ich jetzt
dort einen ratschlag geben weil die
vierte impfung ja keine nennenswerten
nebenwirkungen hat aber trotzdem noch
mal einen schutz gibt dann empfehle ich
die fertigung das tue ich auch gerne
hier in der sendung bei ihnen es ist in
den letzten tagen einer studie
veröffentlicht worden die ich für sehr
wichtig hat in diesem zusammenhang in
israel ist die vierte impfung ja für die
über 60 jährigen empfohlen vier monate
nach der dritten und da hat sich gezeigt
dass im vergleich zur dritten impfung
bei den über 60 hier genauso nicht bald
ein junger bei den über 60-jährigen das
sterberisiko noch einmal ganz deutlich
sehen das macht einen großen unterschied
und ich weiß dass wir derzeit auch viele
60 bis 69 jährige auf den
intensivstationen haben die um ihr leben
ringen mit omikron obwohl sie
vollständig geimpft und gebucht sind
daher also ist der schutz der drei
impfungen sehr gut wurde für die
allgemeine impfpflicht komplett
ausreichend aber derjenige der sich
besonders schützen will und sich selbst
einen gefallen tun will dem würde ich
empfehlen die vierte impfung zu nehmen
dieses jahr ab 70 empfohlen aber auf der
grundlage dieser neuen und sehr
wichtigen studie rechne nicht damit dass
wir das auch noch mal anpassen werden
und das dann ab 60 empfehlen ich habe
den leiter der stiko herrn professor
mertens gebeten dass wir uns zu prüfen
für das bundesgesundheitsministerium die
prüfung beginnt wir sind ein kontakt
aber die studienlage ist aus meiner
sicht eindeutig die über 60-jährigen
gewinnen deutlich an schutz gerade in
der mikrowelle jetzt indem sie eine
vierte impfung nehmen der schutz beginnt
schon eine woche nach der impfung sollte
die impfpflicht scheitern aus ihrer
sicht scheitern treten sie zurück nein
das nicht also ich sags mal so wenn die
impfpflicht scheitern sollte wer eine
vorsichtige konsequenter corona politik
umso wichtiger und ich glaube für diese
stehen zu können ich zeige ihnen eine
frage unserer zuschauerinnen katja mücke
sie fragt uns fragt sie vor allen dingen
wann werden den studien zu den
nebenwirkungen der korona maßnahmen bei
kindern veröffentlicht als
gesundheitsminister tragen sie besonders
verantwortung natürlich für die kinder
auch dafür gibt es so etwas gibt es so
etwas in ihrem ministerium was ganz
gezielt im moment vorangetrieben wird
wir suchen ja die studien die es also zu
den nebenwirkungen der maßnahmen also
gibt auch bei kindern also die suchen
wir systematisch heraus und werten alles
aus was es dazu gibt auch im expertenrat
wir haben ja sehr renommierte also
wissenschaftler kinder also erste
professorin für kinder und
jugendheilkunde professor deutsch und
professor boerne im expertenrat und die
besetzung ist also experten hat habe ich
ja wesentlich mitbestimmt da war es mir
sehr wichtig dass da auch kinder
spezialisten dabei sind die haben die
aufgabe und haben sich dazu auch schon
also immer experten hat geäußert solche
dinge systematisch zu untersuchen dass
die studien die es gibt die werden wir
aus das muss nicht verlangt werden
sondern es wird gemacht das machen die
experten die für das
gesundheitsministerium da im
arbeitsleben sie nicht zurück und sagen
na ja das was wir nicht hin kram ich bin
es nicht ich muss wirklich also hier
also davon nämlich abstand das sind
unterstellungen das machen wir nicht sie
ist einfach die frage wie hält die frage
genau darauf ziele ich habe das
thematisieren sie sich für dieses thema
auch werden sie das mit voller natürlich
voran selbstverständlich also ich habe
ihnen jetzt nicht unterstellt dass sie
mir das vorwerfen das war nicht der bus
dann würdest du angekommen ist dann bin
ich das zu entschuldigen das damit ich
sagen aber es gibt leute im netz die das
unterstellen die also sagen die schauen
nur nach dem koma so maßnahme
veröffentlicht was ihm passt und bastel
und das machen wir nicht das ist der
expertenrat ist vollkommen frei und wir
haben den expertenrat gebeten
ausdrücklich gebeten jedoch mit der
situation von kindern
auseinanderzusetzen und das ist auch
geschehen somit da wird natürlich nichts
nichts verheimlicht haben sie auch alles
getan um über impfnebenwirkungen um die
fälle zu ja diese zu veröffentlichen
darüber zu informieren können sie sagen
unser zuschauern denn diese fragen
kommen das haben sie gerade schon
angedeutet tatsächlicher massenhaft ja
was ist mit all diesen fällen warum
reden sie nicht darüber über diese
impfschäden haben sie alles getan um
darüber zu informieren das tun wir doch
also das paul ehrlich institut ist in
europa besonders renommiert was also die
vorbereitung von zulassung von
arzneimitteln und auch von dem stoffen
angeht und
darüber hinaus also auch was die
erfassung und veröffentlichung von
nebenwirkungen geht da ist kann man
sagen das paul-ehrlich-institut schon
also einer größe auch im europäischen
vergleich das war nicht immer so aber es
ist jetzt so wo andere hinschauen das
paul-ehrlich-institut ist bekannt dafür
in europa sehr also gründlich zu
arbeiten und da hat auch der jetzige
also vorsitzender trip professor jay
khan wesentlichen anteil hat das
wirklich sauber gemacht und also daher
veröffentlichen wir die nebenwirkungen
also
regelmäßig komplett alles was also
geprüft wird auch die qualitätskontrolle
oder also nebenwirkung überprüfung ist
also gewährleistet wird genau
beschrieben und somit wird dann nichts
verheimlicht ich erinnere mich dass er
vor kurzem mal eine krankenkasse der
meinung war da wären nebenwirkungen die
da nicht erfasst werden konnten so das
ist das so soll das kann vorgetragen
werden es war einfach so nach einer
überprüfung das war alles nicht
stichhaltig caravan ist an der der
vorsitzende der kasse musste
zurücktreten nur uns so etwas ist
richtig das muss immer wieder aber wir
sind da wirklich sauber und gehen
präzise vor haben den bogen schlagen von
beginn der sendung über diesen
schrecklichen krieg die folgen die auch
sie sozusagen behandeln müssen in ihrem
bundesgesundheitsministerium natürlich
haben sie zu kämpfen mit der aktuellen
flüchtlings lage mit hunderttausenden
die kommen wahrscheinlich werden ist
über eine million menschen seien
deutlich mehr die nach deutschland auch
kommen viele von ihnen sind ungeimpft
oder können das zumindest nicht
nachweisen völlig klar in den
kriegswirren und möglicherweise ohnehin
völlig klar macht ihnen das sorgen macht
mir sorgen dass genau und das ist auch
ein thema unserer
gesundheitsministerkonferenz morgen wir
werden darüber reden wie wir also die
gesundheitliche versorgung der menschen
die aus der ukraine zu uns geflohen sind
darstellen können dazu zählen auch die
impfungen aber werden wir auch prüfen
welche rolle die impfzentren für die
impfung der geflüchteten menschen
leisten können das ist ein wichtiges
thema so schnell programm zum beispiel
wäre wäre denkbar wäre möglich daran
arbeiten wir wird über nachgedacht hier
geht es ja nicht nur um die korona
impfung sondern hier sind riesige im
flug und auch für andere impfungen und
da versuchen wir einen weg zu finden wie
wir möglichst unbürokratisch und schnell
diese wichtigen impflücken schließen
können in der tat wir reden nicht nur
über corona impfungen auch ganz
wesentlich über masernimpfungen
natürlich das ist zugangsvoraussetzung
in der kita in der schule das stellt im
moment ganz viele die dort in der
leitung sind beispielsweise auch vorgang
schwierige moralische entscheidungen man
möchte diese menschen gerne in die kita
gruppe aufnehmen gerne in die schule
aufnehmen aber man darf es einfach nicht
weil der masern nachweis hier das fehlt
wir arbeiten sie damit um also wir
arbeiten dran ich gehe mit den dingen
immer gleich um also wenn sich bei mir
ein problem
meldet
gbg sofort an die arbeit und das haben
wir hier auch getan und hier arbeiten
wir also mit den gesundheitsministern
der länder nach einem vorschlag an die
sind schon da tja es mal sagen das
gleiche aber ich bleibe dann muss noch
genauer werden als ich schon vor etwa
zwei wochen habe ich also in meinem
ministerium eine arbeitsgruppe gegründet
unter leitung von frau dr teilen gar
nicht mehr lang gar nicht wahrsagen nach
ich will nur für die kita leitung oder
den schulleiter einmal wissen wie soll
der jetzt handelt sollte er erst mal
sagen kommt gar nicht infrage ich nehme
die kinder erstmal nicht auf weil die
haben keinen master nachweis das ist ja
die die rechtliche grundlage genau so
eben wie bei infektionsschutzgesetz
natürlich kann also hier nicht gegen das
recht verstoßen wäre es recht sagt dem
wir haben eine maß an nachweispflicht
und daher also ist das problem hatte ich
aber ich will nur den einen punkt noch
sagen weil mir das wichtig ist also ich
versuche einfach wenn ein problem da ist
er sofort an lösungen zu gehen und hier
haben wir schon also eine arbeitsgruppe
unter leitung von also frau doktor
talstadt die war früher die leiterin des
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst
deutschlandweit hier habe ich
eingestellt eine ganz tolle frau und
mitarbeiterin und die arbeitet in mit
ihrem team bei mir im haus an einer
lösung dieses problems das geht nicht
wenn es geht nicht also sofort aber wir
sind dann schon ziemlich weit und wir
werden darüber morgen mit den
gesundheitsministern der länder sprechen
verstanden stand jetzt ist aber kinder
aus der ukraine
die kein masern nachweis impfnachweis
haben die bleiben draußen lassen sie
werden nicht eine deutsche schule eine
deutsche kita ob wir da eine
pragmatische lösung finden das wird sich
zeigen das wird sich zeigen ob damit
eine ausnahmeregelung arbeiten können
wir müssen mal schauen dazu gehört unter
anderem dass wir uns ein bild davon
machen also wie weit verbreitet sind
eigentlich maß und jetzt bei den kindern
gekommen aber ich glaube wir können das
problem einfach anders wir werden müssen
die kinder aber auch die erwachsenen
hier sehr schnell nachdem sind und daran
arbeiten wir mit hochdruck gesagt die
arbeitsgruppe ist schon anderthalb
wochen in aber das nicht ganz so simpel
weil es ist so dass also die sie müssen
überlegen wo wert geben dort wo die
leute ankommen dort wo sie dann hin
kommen usw man weiß ja gar ländle da
sind die länder zuständig ich habe ja
hier in also im bahnhof habe ich die
chance habe ich das ankommt zentrum
besucht hat mir da ein bild gemacht wird
übersetzt mittel menschen gesprochen
habe versucht mir einen überblick
verschaffen was ob dort überhaupt wissen
ob sie selbst oder ihre kinder geimpft
sind das war zum teil nicht der fall die
wussten gar nicht ob sie geben sind
somit da kommen viele probleme zusammen
aber
probleme sind für die saison da um
gelöst zu werden da bin ich rüber gehend
ist natürlich die kita leiterin der
schulleiter damit alleine da steht jetzt
natürlich hat er das recht vor augen
aber er steht auch von der gewaltigen
moralischen frage und muss das
vorübergehend selbst für sich lösen
genau erreicht aber er kann aber er kann
daher in die kita leiterin kann daher
aber dankbar dafür sein dass bund und
länder schon schnellstmöglich von samana
problem zu lösen ja kurzer strich
drunter unter die sendung mit dem
eigenen geldbeutel sozusagen herr
lauterbach immer wieder die frage auch
nach den krankenkassenbeiträgen
einerseits das große entlastungspaket
von ihrer regierung der ampel regierung
mit geschnürt hunderte euro für jeden
auf der anderen seite ja muss versteuert
werden und so weiter wird schon ein
bisschen was abgeknapst aber jetzt
wollen sich auch noch was haben
krankenkassenbeiträge wieder rauf wie
kommen sie darauf warum muss das sein
steigen gar nicht unmittelbar sondern
hier geht es darum was passieren muss
damit die krankenkasse ein solides jahr
2023 haben und wir müssen aber jetzt
schon mit der planung beginnen wir haben
also
erstklassige gesundheitsversorgung in
der groner krise anbieten können mit
dafür verantwortlich ist diese
versorgung ist mit dafür verantwortlich
dass wir diese gute sterblichkeit und
auch also sag mal im vergleich zu
anderen ländern geringe quote von sehr
schweren erkrankungen hinbekommen haben
das hat geld gekostet
daher haben die krankenkassen viel
ausgegeben sie haben gleichzeitig
einnahmenverluste gehabt was wird ja
über die arbeitnehmer und
arbeitgeberbeiträge bezahlt und wir
haben viele dinge schließen müssen von
daher sind weniger einkommen sind
weniger einnahmen zusammengekommen daher
haben die krankenkassen ist ein defizit
das ist aber kein defizit durch
verschwendung von geld das als auch
ihren eigentlich in jedem ressort
sozusagen das entlastungspaket wieder
das ist dann ein im vergleich zum
entlastungspaket sind die beiträge die
wir zum schluss zusätzlich nehmen müssen
minimal das entlastungspaket ist viel
größer als die summe über die wir hier
reden also im vergleich zum
entlastungspaket sind sind wir in einer
ganz anderen lage zumindest um welchen
anstieg etwas kann ich möchte ich kann
und möchte ich hier nicht sagen das
paket muss endgültig fertig sein und da
wir über einen effizienzreserven
heranziehen die krankenkassen haben zum
glück noch rücklagen dann werden wir
also den beitragssatz ein bisschen
erhöhen es wurde auch mehr steuergeld
geben das wird auch ganz viele schultern
vertrage niemals sagen sie minimal es
wird ein kleiner anstieg seien genau
danke an den bundesgesundheitsminister
hierbei bild danke an karl lauterbach da
gehen wir sind zurück am nächsten
sonntag die richtigen fragen hierbei
[Musik]